imagine that one of your big decisions
for the day
involved choosing between driving your
aston martin
or your ferrari whether to vacation at
your home in
aspen or the one in maine or how about
your private island in the bahamas
imagine that for christmas your husband
presented you with a
43 carat 1.8 million dollar necklace
now flash forward a few years you find
out that your husband of two decades has
been cheating on you with a
20-something russian mistress and he not
only files for divorce
but he tries to get away with not giving
you
anything in short this is what's
happening to marie bosarge
it's a small part of a long drawn-out
legal battle
between her and her husband ed bosarge
the founder of high-speed trading
company
quant lab the bosarge divorce case is
pending in county court here in houston
texas
if it goes to trial the outcome might
rewrite the playbooks for any
tight-fisted billionaires who would like
to leave their spouses
with absolutely nothing
ed and marine bosarge were married in
1989 things were very different back
then
there were no diamonds no mansions her
engagement ring was
cubic zirconia and their house was
repossessed by the bank
soon after they got married but marie
loved her husband and she supported his
efforts during the 1990s in starting a
new high-speed stock trading company
called
quant lab which pioneered the use of
complex
algorithms to squeeze money out of the
stock market
according to court documents the company
has generated net profits of more than
2 billion over the past decade ed and
marie appeared to be living the good
life together
marie was especially fond of their
74-acre island in the bahamas called
over yonder k they docked three yachts
there
one was a 180-footer named after marie
and even featured a baby grand piano
in 2017 when marie was served divorce
papers in her london home
not only was she getting divorced but
she was getting
evicted ed made her leave the london
house
and after that he moved his russian
girlfriend in
marie went back to her texas home a 26
000 square foot palace and found out
that she was getting kicked out of there
too
by orders of the trust that supposedly
owned it
movers emptied the house and even carted
off
her yellow diamond necklace
so why was this allowed to happen to
marie
again she had no prenup no post nup
and texas is a community property state
where the spouse is entitled to
at least 50 of the fruits of the other's
labor
his efforts began back in 1983 with a
trust
set up by his former sister-in-law who
lives in namibia
that trust gradually morphed into about
a dozen
others via a process called decanting
this is where a trustee creates new
trusts
to hold the assets of old trusts kind of
like
pouring wine from one bottle into a
variety of others
over several decades ed allegedly
orchestrated
a murky constellation of asset
protection
trusts domiciled in places as far afield
as
malta the bahamas the british virgin
islands
and even south dakota ed claims that
neither he
nor marie actually owned the houses and
yachts and jewels
that they enjoyed for all those years
rather these
trappings of glamorous lifestyle are
simply
assets owned by one trust or another
so she can't have any of them marie's
predicament has gained local notoriety
thanks to
award-winning reporter turned licensed
private investigator wayne
dolceno he has been retained by friends
of marie to
stir the pot taking paparazzi style
video of bossarj and
posting it on his website i had a zoom
call with wayne recently
let's just say the the man doesn't hold
back every time he had to show up for a
deposition
or to appear in court he would show up
in wheelchairs
and so we shot some video of him
leaving his house to go to his
deposition
and the wheelchair was put in the car
right
but then ed walked out totally fine
totally on his own power
you know he wasn't running or anything
but he was he walked his finders on car
15 minutes later they arrived at the
location of the deposition
and um ed massage has to have the
wheelchair
brought to you i think ed massage when
he wants to be
the dapper playboy um
who's got the young russian girlfriend
out on one of his yachts
he'll show you that video right but when
he
but when he wants to do the other thing
right i'm
really old and feeble he'll play that
one too
so what happens next there are numerous
lawsuits still outstanding
and before covet closed the courts the
bosarjas were headed to trial
on marie's complaint that ed violated
his fiduciary duty to her as a husband
she says it should have looked out for
my interests
forbes reached out to ed bosarge's
attorneys who declined to comment
citing confidentiality orders issued by
the court without addressing specifics
his
attorney john pavlos in an email did
call maria liar
pandemic willing a trial in harris
county family court in texas will come
in november
if marie prevails down here she could
then take that ruling back to south
dakota courts
and try once again to get ed to open up
his secret trusts